hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to the plague again the girl
killer indie horror game of terror
unlike any other so I've heard
WASD to move shift or run you will
fatigue brackets citrine hello that was
a little intense brackets to change
mouse sensitivity f2 toggle full screen
to skip the pause okay hold left mouse
button to collect pumpkins will relight
your candle you do not have to collect
all the pumpkins there already then
follow the signs to find your way out
tip they spawn near the huge trees for
better experience we recommend
headphones and playing in a dark
environment not really because I have a
spotlight on my face but otherwise it's
kind of kind of dark Tando so you can
see my beautiful face
whoa the Great Plague of London 31
October 1666 hello well someone's having
a midnight snack so dark I need my
candle I concur
grab the candle from your little shelf
well if I could so there we are I got it
oh hello berry Barrington how are you
doing I'm a little concerned as to
what's going on down stair well best to
charge in headfirst because I can't
imagine how I'll look at all this blood
Wow
oh he's running away from me
am I the monster Amaya the scary one I
mean this seems to be my house he was
eating his face off
oh no I have seen it before how does he
got for me okay I appreciate modern
technology in 1666 but I'm pretty sure
they didn't have automatic doors
especially ones it looks like a coffin
how it's got for me I have to get out of
here why why are you here the what zero
out of 1195 find the graveyard gate all
right
pumpkins I don't know that means I
thought they were just for real I my
candle against Kazak uno vs beer care
who say sorry pray who loot as wise
words everyone should live by absolutely
there's a big moon in the distance what
am I supposed to do I don't imagine
wandering around in the middle of though
oh I wish it was so intense when I was
gathering these little pumpkins nothing
what is with the weird claw hands coming
up to block my face every time I blink
as a worst blinking mechanic ever Orson
SI p that's pretty good okay now this is
not actually me blinking there really
are hands that are coming up to my face
okay so I don't know exactly no the
objective of this who why what why why
Oh pumpkin god damn pumpkin where are
you I can't see a thing no pumpkins
no no dreams all lost what is that in
the distance Oh God
I can't see where I'm going there's
noises in the darkness okay alright then
I ran into a wall I have no idea where
I'm gone can I find wood wide-set my
harpy I got it now is easy hello hello
is that big guy okay so it said sign
spawn near huge trees this guy doesn't
look exactly puny so I'm gonna guess
it's gonna be a sign around him whoa
look it's a sign perfect
how's my favorite movie by M night sham
lamb lamb blue okay so I need to go this
way I don't know what that means I saw
pumpkin off to the left but I'm not
gonna get it because I'm sure yeah it's
gonna be plenty of pumpkins on the way
so long as I keep my ride
what [ __ ] you well I'm dead
sleep tight Tim see who's 10 years old
what the freaking frack house no yours
there they didn't tell me I was 10
wells made pretty adult decisions don't
you think all right whatever never
looked the doctor in the eyes okay then
just a ten-year-old kid that lives in a
graveyard keeps all the dead bodies and
gets my morning meals from uncle Jerry
who I devour the face up so dark I need
my Gandil I agree also I need 1,000
pumpkins to be able to see cuz I'm a
little kid with really thick eyelashes
[Music]
no need to run that fast
so uncle Jerry don't look so good maybe
he want pumpkin okay let's go back out
there see if I can actually do a little
better than Sam I don't even know what I
did wrong
wait why didn't it okay there we go
see I don't know if I'm supposed to
actually seek out the punk oh look a
sign doesn't that point exactly back to
the house
Church Oh Oh go your way you rogue
what say you bastard
all right trust in this cuz if it's
wrong then where the hell am I going
[Music]
baby
well my mommy 10-year old baby where I
got cut damn it with this thing I
thought I saw something that the
pumpkins honor they would call
considering they have candles in them
Jacqueline hurts and all whatever wait
there was another one right here
I ain't gonna lie to me I know what I
saw all right whatever distrust thousand
three hundred twenty-five was randomly
generated I bet it is mystery is leave
me alone doc
all right blinking my big eyelashes oh
my god hey no no step e step no crunchy
leaves besides mine is gamblin Ranger
danger come on
why do you gotta be mean to little Tim
Tim this is sea urchin a tiny box Tam
before he was stuffed in a box stuffed
into a coffin
okay I thought it wasn't supposed to do
all that let me let me read this again
Han do not have to collect all the
pumpkins follow the signs to find your
way out do tell me to I couldn't even
see the doctor when he was there maybe
this is me maybe this is little Tim Tim
being a little dumb-dumb there's so dark
I need my Kindle hey Doc
stop that yeah I know you could have
killed me right here now I'm glad you
did
well dem Dems happy by Jerry I'm going
out for a walk in the woods Thank You
creepy automatic doors
[Music]
find the graveyard get 3597 goddamn
besides how big could this graveyard
possibly be do I get like you know
supplies or parents how do I get any of
that school ins this 1666 best grave
guards were a bullying business back in
the day
yeah I'm really thinking that the creepy
crawlies headed here that wall okay well
good dynamic shadow shading it's good
stuff I like it
I think the creepy-crawlies in the other
parts of the woods that I hear are
actually the doc cuz I seem to hear that
right before my death you know what he's
walking out there I know he's watching
me
look
I really understood as a horror game
that had a microphone that was
interactive in the environment so the
was shouting by myself and I can shout
no okay
I freaked myself out there for a second
never mind everyone ignore me for a
second I thought after I got that
pumpkin that things went wrong but
apparently they did not I cannot see a
thing all right even see a big tree I
need a guy a star inside oh good now
it's brighter I think can't tell oh god
damn my big eyelashes my big beautiful
eyelashes maybe fly flutter them at the
done now that'd be weird I'm 10 years
old I think
who knows maybe he's just a murderess
and a pedophile makes sense and a
cannibal he's also a cannibal oh god
damn you the [ __ ] what do I get out my
dad I'm not dead they're gonna find a
pumpkin
it's a weirdest thing to say after
you've been attacked by a plague doctor
I gotta find a pumpkin I'll never get
out of here if I don't find another
token
all right tiny pumpkin Tim going on here
got my head chopped off oh god wait
there's a wall there's a big wall oh god
why can't I find any bargains why don't
the pumpkins glow damn it that's game so
dark come on there we go well this looks
like a lot of things wait a minute wait
a minute this looks important what is
this okay I collected 45 pump just what
is this I thought okay that's good right
I think that's good okay where's the big
sign how comes it was not a trap Tim
okay maybe the plague has gotten to your
brain a little bit because you're
greater really suffering I know it's
London Times but coati has invented
English sign yes go that way I shall I
shall go that way that way leads tours
maybe I'm close everyone close to the
end maybe I'm gonna make it maybe I'm
gonna survive oh no that's not what I'm
gonna do the opposite of that oh come on
with this thing in the need of the
pumpkins it's dark start dating it's a
whole lot of dark you can't see a damn
thing don't I have the key and close to
the end
walk along Megillah way downtown walking
fast fences passing home ban - don't
kill me bro right now bro oh oh I only
wanted to relieve you from your pain
hide we can't rub away the world is this
from the plague can't run from the
plague relief me from my pain please
okay that wasn't bad it was really dark
though I mean the mechanics of the
pumpkins were a little interesting and I
only found the key by sheer luck but
anyway it wasn't that bad it was an
interesting spin on the go collect
mechanics in the dark it wasn't that bad
let me know what you think of the
comments below let me know if you can
get the high score maybe there's a big
secret if you find all the pumpkins I
didn't even understand the plague doctor
but either way hope you guys enjoyed it
hope you got a scare out of it thank you
all so much for watching check in the
description for more scary games that
I've done in the past
there's a whole lot of them and as
always I'll see you in the next video
[Music]
[Applause]